what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with more X-Men content because
you guys have been screaming for this
we're doing X-Men red now here's one
thing I want to specify for those who
are current on X-Men red we're only
covering one through four here and the
reason why is because five and six are
tie-ins for the Judgment Day event so
the only way to make those make sense is
to actually do those as tie-ins for our
coverage of Judgment Day so that's why
we're calling this volume one even
though it's only one through four having
said that for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with X-Men red this story is
amazing what this does here is this
initially opens up by answering the
question how it is that storm became the
queen regent of Mars I.E or Rocco
because remember where you initially had
the end of The Inferno event ten of
Swords all that kind of stuff and you
had a Rocco and krakowa that were
supposed to merge into a singular land
mass back to the way they used to be
that was rejected and so instead oracco
ended up being taken to Mars and it
basically operates there right so it's
kind of a place where the citizens of
Morocco can live their own life because
the the citizens of Morocco and in the
citizens of krakowa they have distinctly
different views on things and in fact
that's going to be a main focus of this
story but the way that storm got her
position was actually by challenging
nameless the shapeshifter Queen who can
basically take on the form of whoever it
is she's facing or virtually anybody and
duplicate their powers as well so she's
not really similar to Mystique as much
as she is Copycat Vanessa Carlisle who
can not only shapeshift into people but
also take their powers or copy their
powers as well and so she actually
shape-shifted into storm when she was at
her Peak which is a nice little touch by
Tom Taylor here but as the tour they
were basically fighting of course storm
ultimately comes out on top indirectly
in the sense that she actually freezes
uh nameless in her place and instead of
accepting defeat nameless simply kills
herself now one of the things that I
want to specify here is that the The
Challenge and and really the fight for
from nameless isn't based strictly on
her position and what is in effect the
arako version of The Quiet Council on
krakowa right arako's own governing body
essentially it's this idea that storm is
seen as an outsider the reality here is
a Rocco's the the iraqan people see or I
guess the Iraqi as are pronounced they
see krakowens as Outsiders and so storms
showing up here and challenging in Iraqi
for her position is such that it's seen
as an outsider challenging a rightful
ruler But ultimately the the role is
maintained right the challenge is upheld
storm wins and she ends up gaining a
seat on the great Ring of araka which
again is a Rocco's version of The Quiet
Council on krakowa and so as a result of
this you do have a have an interesting
list here among these and really the
most intriguing is iska the unbeaten now
of course you also do have Tarn and will
end up talking about him shortly right
we'll talk about him here in a little
bit but iska the unbeaten who's going to
be a particularly important part of the
story here in a little while those of
you guys who are unfamiliar with her
she's the one that can never lose right
so whatever it's one of those things
where she's like let's say for example
that you have a battle to the death
right say for example that Magneto's
fighting Xavier but iska could look at
that and safe I think Magneto's gonna
win Magneto's Victory is guaranteed no
matter what side she chooses it's just
kind of one of those giant Mary suits
but we're gonna find one of these really
interesting elements where her power can
actually be used against her but you do
get a few things where stuff's kind of
settling in for example Magneto after
resigning from the quiet Council took up
residence on oracco now one of the
reasons why really the big reason why
Magneto resigned from the council was
the aftermath of Inferno Maura McTaggart
all that kind of stuff the reality of
what had been done basically being
leaked out to the rest of of krakowa and
the fact that the hidden agenda of Maura
McTaggart was that she believed that the
only way to save the mutant population
was to get rid of it so to basically
manipulate the entire Resurrection
process so that as mutants were
resurrected they would ultimately be
resurrected without their powers and it
would be assumed that something went
wrong or whatever it was but it would be
Beyond contestation and because of the
fact that these mutants would be
resurrected as essentially humans they
would be banished from cocoa and so
ultimately more mctaggard could weed the
mutant population down to nothing Xavier
and Neato saw this as a massive betrayal
and in the aftermath of everything
Magneto quit he was just disillusioned
with krakowa in a lot of ways so what do
you guys are doing of course showing up
here in arako ends up coming across what
is basically a fisherman this guy's
gonna be referred to as Kingfisher later
on down the line but it's a cool little
thing here because this guy is one where
he sort of teaches Magneto the nature of
what it means to truly be an a Rocco
citizen in the sense that where Magneto
asked him like is this land yours his
response is it's everybody's land right
this is not like krakowa and you guys on
Earth where you slice up sections of
land and say now this belongs to me
nobody else can have this he's like this
is for everybody here right land existed
before we were here before you were here
it'll exist after you're dead it does
not belong to any one particular person
because you've arbitrarily claimed
dominion over it that's not how we do
things here and so of course it's really
kind of a way for Magneto to kind of get
back to his roots to understand what it
means to truly be part of something
bigger and in fact Magneto is also going
to experience a paradigm shift here now
following that we switch over to what's
basically called like the Red Bar
essentially right the red Lagoon as it's
called so again much of what you see
here on a Rocco is kind of an extension
of krakowa just with different names
right cocoa has the green Lagoon arako
has the red Lagoon because Mars is a red
planet and so of course this whole place
is basically led by Robert DeCosta
Sunspot which is a cool little touch
here but you do have Gabriel Summers
Vulcan now vulcan's gonna be a huge part
of this story but at the moment
something that you'll probably notice
between Hickman's run and this run is
that Vulcan is a lot more angry right
he's much angrier than he used to be and
a lot more mentally unstable now this is
kind of explained from a couple
different places the first one is from
Jerry Dugan's X-Men run with Issue
Number 10 which we haven't necessarily
covered yet but it's also explained here
so we're going to kind of jump forward
in the story for a second but the
reality is that for those of you guys
who recall the war of King's Story and
really just the nature of Volcan himself
that when the events of the rise and
fall of the Shia Empire took place which
was basically where Vulcan had learned
the reality of his parents death or at
least his mother's death at the hands of
like the shiar that he was born on the
Shia Shia home world all that kind of
stuff learning his true history he
traveled to the Shia Empire and then
ultimately conquered it and became its
Emperor this eventually led to an event
called The War of kings and it kind of
happened by just different circumstances
it wasn't a direct continuation but you
ended up getting the war of Kings where
it was like Black Bolt versus Volcan and
then that led to a great big huge
conflict which ripped a Fisher in space
that's what led to Thanos imperative in
the cancer verse that during that story
Vulcan was basically pulled into the
cancer verse and was dissected by these
different aliens and what they had done
based on these plans that have really
haven't come to fruition yet again this
is kind of a big retcon that what they'd
done with uh with Vulcan is they had
suppressed his true personality and then
essentially replace it with a more toned
down and relaxed personality and so that
is the way that Tom Taylor is explaining
how it is that we went from like the
crazy ultraviolent Vulcan back in the
day to like suddenly this moretone down
relax and chill Vulcan that we suddenly
saw during Hickman's run now whether
that was the initial plan with this
character and it's just now coming to
fruition or Tom Taylor's doing his own
thing I don't really know here but
that's the way that was done the kicker
here is that during times of like
emotional distress and so on the true
personality of Vulcan starts to come out
and that's what's going on here because
it was believed that Vulcan had died
even though he had never actually died
that when he was kind of out of the
picture this led to Gladiator taking
control of the Shia Empire really just
on a kind of replacing Vulcan as its
ruler and then passing that down to
Zandra who is basically a girl that has
the genetic material of both Xavier and
Leandra so he wasn't she wasn't really
born by way of the two of them just like
touching naughty bits but just their
genetic material when they were both
basically dead that this kind of pisses
him off he sees himself as the rightful
heir to the throne of the shiar but he's
not ruling the shiar and he's not seen
as an emperor of the Shia now a lot of
this goes into the always existing
desire of broken to be adored and in
fact this is going to be preyed on later
because this kind of argument here leads
to a skirmish which actually sees
Abigail brand and cable stepping in and
basically bringing it into it now one of
the things to know here is that the most
recent video that we did that had cable
had his younger self now we have his
older self the explanation for this here
is that there came a point when Strife
returns Strife basically being the clone
of cable from the future that's
basically a bad guy the younger version
of cable realized the only way to beat
Strife was to bring his older version
back and when that was done because of
the rules of krakowa saying that there
can't be two of the same kind of person
walking around the younger cable went
back to his own future and the older
cable stayed behind from a publishing
side it was Marvel just getting rid of
the younger cable which nobody was
really receptive to he was kind of a
cool character but a lot of people just
want to see the old cable now this is
probably also due to the fact that like
the Marvel Cinematic Universe now has
Deadpool Josh Brolin's cable is probably
going to come back in some way so
they're just doing things to kind of
bring stuff further in line with the MC
you uh but beyond that is basically this
Marvel kind of setting things back to
normal so that's how you get older cable
here instead of younger cable younger
cable wasn't aged up or anything like
that but the thing behind this is
Abigail brand recognizes the desire of
Gabriel Summers to be adored by the
people around him and she initially
starts to use it as a kind of weapon
right sort of manipulating him to a
degree now the other part of this and
we'll kind of gets that manipulation
here in a second the other part of this
is the nature of storm herself one of
the things to know and it's what's so
interesting about Tom Taylor's writing
here is the value of storm and the the
idea behind storm is largely relegated
to you understanding the history of
storms storms whole history in a lot of
ways has been facing off against various
people to establish herself in some kind
of a leadership role but what she never
wanted was to be seen as some kind of a
dictator or definitive ruler whose
authority is beyond contestation she
never wanted to be seen that way and so
that's why even during this this
instance where she's talking like the
iska the unbeaten and they're talking
about how like she's a queen she's in
this like position of a Authority no one
can question her so on and so forth that
the response to storm is no but if I'm
going to live among the oracco people I
cannot show up here as a curcumen and
say I wrestled control from your
previous leader now I am the leader
everybody has to do what I say no that
the entire basis behind the people of
Morocco is they fight together they die
together and they live together there is
a far greater sense of community among
the people of Morocco than there is
virtually anybody on Earth and storm
recognizes that so even when people
behind the scenes try to manipulate her
or challenge her or what have you and
saying like you're an absolute Queen
here you have an absolute Authority
storm rejects it even going so far as to
destroy the throne on a Rocco and saying
there are no Thrones here there are no
definitive leaders there are those of us
with some measure of authority but at
the end of the day we work with those
around us as opposed to as opposed to
over those who are around us and that's
what's kind of crazy here is because
what you end up getting is literally
Robert DeCosta who shows up to Magneto
in this new Palace he's created it for
himself or I called the Autumn Palace
which is just an amazing name for a
citadel also being joined alongside
fisher king who actually is from Morocco
but doesn't have any powers so about as
close as you can get to like a
traditional human being but one of the
things that he had established is that
because of the fact that he had fought
and bled among the arako people he
basically earned their respect so sure
he does not have powers but he is of
arako and they respect his
accomplishments because for the people
of Morocco it's less about what powers
you have and more about what you've
accomplished in terms of like earning
honorable recognition among like
fighting among them and being like a
genuine person and so on and so forth
and so where Robert Acasa again shows up
here and says look Abigail Brands up to
something and she is inevitably going to
form her own team she's going to form
what is essentially going to be her
version of the X-Men we have to have
something to counter that the response
of of Magneto is I mean we can but like
I don't want to be some kind of an X-Man
and the reality here is that if we are
going to do this I don't want to be
someone who stands apart from the arako
people right I want to be a part of the
Oracle people themselves to fall in line
with their beliefs and their Customs
because it's more in line with what I
believe on a personal level this leads
to storms showing up and saying I
believe the exact same thing if we are
going to form a team here then it needs
to be a team that is of the iroquo
people and when the question by Magneto
is asked then what's the balance right
who defends the broken land the response
of storm is the Brotherhood does so in
effect you basically have Abigail brand
forming your own X-Men team storm and
Magneto in them are forming their own
team called the Brotherhood but the
other thing behind this this is
something else to keep in mind is that
there comes a point when we end up
finding out that Gabriel summers at
Vulcan is far more unstable than we
initially thought so much so did he
actually created energy constructs in
the form of Petra and swag now Petra and
sway were two members of the original I
guess the second version of the X-Men
that were created in secret that were
introduced during the original X-Men
deadly Genesis story arc so you're
welcome to check out that story if you
want to to get a better understanding of
it but the truth is that they're not
actually there they're not actually a
life and when Gabriel Summers is
confronted by this information by Xavier
who's actually been trying to work with
Gabriel in order to show him he's
becoming mentally unstable but being an
Omega Level mutant with the ability to
control virtually any form of energy
that this presents as a very dangerous
situation that Xavier says Hey like so
we've made some some modifications and
some enhancements with cerebro we can
bring back all kinds of people now right
we can bring back like Thunderbird or
changeling or Petra and sway who were
not actually here even though you see
them they Gabriel rejects it and in
doing so actually just attacks everybody
and kills Xavier in Cyclops in the
process now where they are resurrected
the reality is that because of his
mental instability he's banned from The
Summer's house he's not allowed to
return and so this is why Abigail brand
is using the mental instability of
Gabriel to her Advantage even going so
far is saying like I get that what you
want is the is recognition and
recognition is what you deserve so what
I suggest you do is you challenge Tarn
the uncaring for his seat on the ground
great circle right for his seat on the
throne or at least on as part of the
inner Council for arako you challenge
him not only that I also want you to
join my newly assembled X-Men team which
is like cable whose name speaks for
himself right like manifold who can
teleport frenzy which is cool to see
that they're still doing something with
her I've been a fan of her ever since
her introduction I think it was her
introduction in the old X Factor Comics
right X Factor issue number five uh with
apocalypse it's cool to see that kind of
stuff right like it's cool to see that
they kind of maintain these characters
but it's really her bringing Gabriel on
to the team launching their own X-Men
and what ends up happening in their
first outing is they actually respond to
what is in effect some kind of just
crazy science hits with these giant
robots Each of which has powers that are
basically looking to attain information
from Morocco right like literally
looking to like conquer a Rocco or not
really conquer it but like steal from
the people and attack them and so on and
so forth just your normal villain kind
of stuff the big difference here is that
when Abigail Brand's team shows up here
on the scene that Gabriel Summers kind
of becomes an extension of his own
arrogance in the sense that cable is
annihilated almost immediately and that
where Abigail Brands like look we have
to get these people away we have to
protect them so on and so forth the
response of of really like a frenzy and
even a few other people here are like no
they don't want to be like rescued they
don't want to be saved what they want is
they want to fight to save their own
land this is a proud people they're used
to fighting for what for for what
belongs to them we have to work
alongside them in this way but even
Gabriel Summers rejects it and it's just
kind of like these are like powerless
people who are small right they haven't
there's nothing there so he literally
tells them go away right like everybody
you just need to leave so on and so
forth and tries to impose his own will
onto them which of course they reject
this leads to him actually empowering up
to attack them only for him to be frozen
in place by storm and the Brotherhood
who arrive on the scene and then
contrary to what Abigail Brand's team
was doing that you actually have fisher
king again who's recognized as some
measure of a champion among the arako
people who approaches them and says hey
look I'm a part of this team called the
Brotherhood we're not here to force you
to like disperse we're here because we
recognize what you all are capable of
you have fought and you have bled for
the land that you value fought and bleed
alongside us as we help you cast off
these forces that's what the iroco
people are receptive to and so where
Magneto could not initially get a
foothold and using his power on these
giant robots due to their ability to
protect themselves from the
electromagnetic abilities of Magneto
himself that in all these forces
gathering together while they're not the
most powerful and they could never
defeat these things on their own what it
does do is it grants a distraction and
then a distraction Magneto is able to
find a weakness and in doing so destroys
these guys and so when that takes place
you of course have Gabriel Summers who
just lashes out angry at the fact that
he never died and in fact he goes to
attack storm only for storm to overpower
him now this is something that you don't
normally see all that often and in fact
it's a phenomenal concept because she's
just like look right you manipulate
energy and so do I you are an Omega
Level mutant and so am I this is not a
clash of mutant weapons this is a battle
of will feel the power Circle us
building from one to the other seeking a
weakness a break and our armor a flaw
you speak of a fire that burns inside
you a flame Dancing In The Wind inside
me child is the hurricane and she just
like wow just like overpowers this guy
and knocks him out and it's crazy to see
storm overpower Vulcan that way it just
shows how capable she is it's kind of
astounding and so in the aftermath of
this and the fact that Vulcan has
suffered such a humiliating defeat that
Abigail brand again feeds on this and
saying now is your time to challenge
Tarn the uncaring now's your time to
overpower this guy and take his position
on the throne and so that's exactly what
happens right that what you end up
getting is a couple different things one
Magneto is approached by Robert DeCosta
in saying you should also Vie for a
position on the throne as well you
should challenge Tarn the uncaring to
take his place as opposed to allowing
Abigail bran to put one of her people on
the throne right it's literally A Game
of Thrones it's a game of politics it's
basically what this is Magneto initially
shoots a sit down and it's like no I
don't want to be in that position that
role again I don't want to do that and
so what we end up doing is switching
over to Gabriel Summers facing off
against Tarn now this is a cool thing
because this is where is the unbeaten
comes in that you have Robert DeCosta
who sits down next to her and the two of
them just kind of have this discussion
and the question is asked like who do
you think could actually win here
against these two guys and iska doesn't
really provide much of an answer right
just because of the fact that she wants
to abstain she doesn't want to really
sway things either way but it is
particularly intriguing here because
what you have are two wildly powerful
beings so Vulcan has the ability to
manipulate any form of energy it doesn't
matter what it is he just has to be
taught about that energy that's it what
you also have is Tarn who can actually
control the DNA structure of anybody
around him he can shut off Powers he can
give Powers he can like heal people he
can do all kinds of stuff if it's a DNA
structure he can manipulate it which
makes him ridiculously powerful because
what actually goes on here is that him
realizing that Gabriel Summers can
manipulate any form of energy tauren
shuts his power off just like that and
that's why I say like like mutants like
this like turn the uncaring leech people
like that they are ridiculously powerful
because of what use is someone who can
alter reality if their power is taken
away with the powers of Gabriel Summers
being shut off by turn the uncaring then
it comes down to just a straight up
one-on-one battle and like literally
Tarn the uncaring is a far more
formidable opponent in just physical
combat than Gabriel Summers is and he
beats him to death he literally snaps
his arm and then just kills him and so
at that point he's like I remain
unbeaten is there anyone else out there
right is there no one else that can
offer a credible challenge here and
that's when a voice comes out of nowhere
and says I will challenge you and it
turns out to be Magneto now this is
where things get interesting because
where torn's Powers had shut off the
powers of Gabriel at the same time that
Gabriel had shut off the powers of Tarn
that what you have here is his powers
coming back now that Gabriel's dead and
he doesn't have the ability that his
powers have no effect anymore and so
that's when iska says this is poor
timing right torn's powers are returning
he'll stall another moment then
Slaughter the old fool and the response
of Robert DeCosta is sadly I have to
agree iska I bet you Tarn wins and
because there was a bit of momentary
banter between the two where they were
just kind of going back and forth and
kind of you know basically just being in
opposition to each other as a kind of
instinctual gut reaction like iska the
unbeaten just kind of thinks no I bet
Magneto wins and that solidifies the
victory of Magneto literally her power
was manipulated and that's the kicker to
iska the unbeaten that on the surface
and the way she was originally
introduced during Hickman's run she was
a Mary Sue right it was just kind of
like well you know uh I never lose so
whatever side I choose wins and that's
basically it even her own decisions are
not necessarily her own but with Robert
DeCosta manipulating her due to like the
friendly banter between the two that
momentary thought of nope I bet Magneto
wins that solidifies the victory of
Magneto and that's exactly what happens
right that quite literally like Magneto
realizes the nature of tarn's powers and
he literally takes his helmet off and
attaches it to tarn's head and he says
okay so like we're tarn's like trying to
figure out what's going on the response
of Magneto is we're allowed non-mutant
weapons as I understand it your control
of DNA is psychokinetic in nature
meaning you use your mind to do it my my
helmet blocks mental powers and it's
made of metal so he's like goodbye Tarn
and just crushes the helmet around the
head of Tarn and kills him on the spot
and Magneto wins it's it's so cool
because this this is one of the best
moments ever because what it solidifies
is Magneto being as capable as he is is
not just limited to his powers it's
limited to how he thinks it's limited to
how he is it's based on how he sees
things that because Magneto has been
around for so long and he's fought so
many different people of such varying
levels of power that to fight him is to
fight on a three-dimensional level
considering all possibilities from all
possible directions that's one of the
things that makes him such a capable guy
you take his just Intelligence on the
battlefield field you combine it with
its powers and you have the
quintessential definition of an Omega
Level being right just an Unstoppable
being and so that's when things get cool
because what this does kind of a quick
little moment here right what this does
is there are two things that come out of
it and that what Magneto does is he
presents a resurrection orb to the
governing body of a Rocco and what they
initially ask is this your gift to us
right the ability for us to resurrect
the response of Magneto is no you value
your lives based on what you do here not
some kind of endless you know going on
forever Resurrection process he's like
but I value you know I value my life
where I had previously value in my life
based on my ability to return because
Magneto had died and come back several
times and he says but if I'm going to be
of the people of Morocco then I will
live as the people of Morocco do I will
be one of you I will not stand outside
of you and so in destroying this orb
what it actually contains are the
backups of storm and Magneto in effect
if they die they're gone right like as
we know them they can be resurrected on
krakowa but nothing they they recall
here will ever be brought back with them
they'll literally start back at square
one and so what it means is that their
life here matters more than it ever did
before now were the questions asked by
the council okay cool but you are also
here as a representative of storm where
is storm and why isn't she here the
respond to Magneto is because there's
something else bigger going on here and
so what we end up doing is we switch to
storm in a conversation that she's
having really with like Oracle and a few
other people by way of Black Panther in
the sense that like there is a massive
Calamity that has happened that what's
taken place here and this will become a
major plot thread going into like the
future of the X-Men red storyline that
what had happened here is Zandra the
leader of the shiar Empire has died and
that with the Empress of the Shia empire
being killed what it now means is the
Empire is destabilized that there will
basically be a situation whereby The
Fringe world the galactic Rim will
actually start vying for this power
vacuum that it could lead to a civil war
among the Shia Empire among those who
are looking to take control and so the
big question that's being asked here is
what do we do because the biggest
concern here is that this could turn
into an astronuclear War a repeat of the
operation Galactic Storm Conflict which
technically was caused by the cree but
it saw the detonation of this bomb that
killed trillions of beings and that
could very well be a repeat here right a
civil war on a galactic scale countless
individuals could die and so in the
presence of like Richard Ryder Nova and
like all these different guys the
questions asked like what do we do and
the initial response and even black
panther kind of chimes in and says I
mean the curcumans have the power of
Resurrection why not just resurrect her
well then at that point the galactic Rim
raises this really interesting question
and they say no we reject that because
why should the empress receive the right
of Resurrection when nobody else can
right when the average citizen can't or
her subjects can't or the people who
fight alongside her cannot receive that
why does she receive some kind of
special treatment not only that if we do
invoke the krakowan concept of
Resurrection then what we effectively do
is we put an immortal dictator on the
seat of the throne the reality of the
nature of any Empire is that people have
their Time by whatever Manner and
whatever means they serve as an emperor
for whatever time period And when they
die they die and a new one takes over
the correct course of action here is to
appoint a new empress and the reality
here is that storm says that's not going
to happen because here's the issue where
you Oracle right the telepath and
advisor of the of the Shia race where
you picked up on this just kind of huge
amount of Mind data that was released by
zondra as an Omega Level mutant herself
right as you when you picked up on all
this information the question you have
to ask yourself is was it really meant
for you right outside of being some kind
of an advisor to the Shia race it was
never meant for you right it was never
your purpose to have all this
information it's cool that you made us
aware of this but the target of that
information was Charles Xavier of the
X-Men and Xavier has received that
information and Xavier has used that
information the way he thought zondra
wanted that information to be used and
he's resurrected her so this argument is
over now we are done your Empress has
been brought back your Ambush will be
restored and everything in the Shia
Empire will be maintained that's kind of
the irony of all this because at the end
of the day no matter what's being done
here no matter what storm is saying here
and so far is saying like I don't want
to be seen as some kind of a dictatorial
queen ruling this place with an iron
fist the reality is she's operating that
way this storm is falling down this path
of just becoming this absolute ruler and
so the question is going to be or at
least has to be asked what happens when
the time comes that someone challenges
that that someone stands to her or even
the arako people stand against her
what's that going to look like but with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end the next time you
see our coverage of X-Men red will be
during the events of Judgment Day so
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later peace